there's this self-fulfilling prophecy  that happens often within the incel  community where it's bad for society not  to help them the very isolation and  rejection Etc that they suffer leads  them to the path where they find  negative Role Models like Jordan  Peterson and Andrew Tate and then they  end up blaming everyone else for their  misery instead of maybe looking more at  themselves and changing themselves and  they end up adopting some of the worst  traits of the people that they follow  it's not just Jordan Peterson and Andrew  Tate there's all sorts of like Charisma  coaches and pickup artists and all this  different stuff and it makes them even  less desirable to the very people they  are trying to appeal to so we've got to  figure out how to do something